Pedro Sánchez podría dimitir como
Presidente del gobierno el próximo lunes.
El líder del ejecutivo
se aparta de la actividad
política durante 5 días para reflexionar
acerca de su futuro
después de que la justicia
haya abierto diligencias contra su mujer.
Vamos a recordar que Begoña Gómez
está siendo investigada
por su relación con distintas
empresas de carácter privado
que acabaron
recibiendo fondos y contratos públicos del ejecutivo.
De momento
el juez solo ha llamado a declarar a algunos testigos
para intentar aclarar cuál era
la verdadera relación de la mujer del Presidente
con estas empresas.
De momento, Pedro Sánchez se aparta de la vida pública
hasta el próximo lunes,
cuando compadecerá para
comunicar su decisión
sobre si sigue o no como Presidente del gobierno
y esta tarde ha hecho pública
esta carta
en la que dice que todo esto es 1 maniobra política
de la derecha
y que es 1 hombre profundamente
enamorado de su mujer.
Podría ser 1 telenovela, pero no lo es